everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today are going to be going
over game 6 from the 2013 World Chess
Championships from the first four games
they were all draws game 5 Magnus
Carlsen finally broke through with our
first win of the tournament and if
you've been keeping up with it every
game so far has been more exciting than
the last so coming into game six I I
didn't really know what to expect we had
an on playing the white pieces
definitely looking for a win himself so
he can get back to even in this game
Magnus Carlsen and you know my opinion
can just kind of play forward the draw
but it's getting to the point where you
know he has in my opinion more stamina
he's a little younger and so he can kind
of just grind down and on and get
himself in in game situations where he
feels comfortable where he can either
draw or actually play for the win if his
opponent makes a dumb move so we're
gonna go ahead and get into it non
starts with pani for pani 5 9 f3 knight
c6 and we see the Rui Lopez this bishop
coming out here to b5 and Magnus Carlsen
defends the same way that he did just a
few games ago with the Berlin defense
now in that game we actually saw the
Keane castling and then this knight
comes down here and takes here on e4 and
then we saw pawn here to d4 and this put
through your game and now I decided to
play a little bit different from that
game Magnus Carlsen drew the game but
almost won and so instead and on plays
this pawn to d3 which he's had a lot of
success with in the past playing a high
level play and so I think this fits an
on style a little bit better Magnus
Carlsen responds with Bishop here to c5
with the intent of he wants to get it
outside this pawn chain he can play his
own pawn here to d6 kind of solidifying
that pawn structure but you know
maintaining this control along this you
know long diagonal right here
same thing with an on you can always
bring his Bishop back to this long file
or this long diagonal and kind of try to
control this right now but so we
definitely have a much different Berlin
defense than we had before
now anon decides to play pawn to c3 you
know he had a lot of options here he
could have castled on the King side if
he wanted to he could just immediately
played his bishop coming out here could
have played Knight to c3 so definitely
some options from him chose the
interesting pawn here at c3 you know
later he can push forward with his pawn
to d4
you know he may want to get his Bishop
out and then get his knight involved
definitely interesting moved though not
one that I see too often in the Berlin
defense but you know my guess is anons
been studying this for the past few
months and definitely find some lines
that he thinks gives him the advantage
magnus carlsen now decides to go ahead
and castle on the kingside and anon does
the same both sides just continue their
developments the risk in the swing over
here per you know adding more protection
on this pawn here on e5 the ropes gonna
come over a1 do the exact same thing and
then blacks gonna start to push this
bishop away this is gonna be completely
fine for both sides I think I think you
know white kind of enjoys bringing his
bishop back here to b3 this is a very
active square him for magnus carlsen
again he now has pushed a little bit on
the Queen side but now he has this
entire diagonal for his bishop here just
to kind of rain down so both sides have
a lot of pressure so it looks like we
could definitely have some fireworks in
this game as both sides could have a
potential strong attack either way now
we haven't seen any pieces or pawns
moved off the board but we could in the
near future
now that pawn is gonna come to d6 is
kind of we talked about solidifying this
pawn chain but he already has his dark
square bishop out of the pawn chain so
it's definitely okay and now this dark
square bishop comes to g5 definitely one
of those strong moves again there's no
great square for it to come to you know
something d2 is gonna be too passive you
know III is is a novel idea to try to
you know get this Bishop off which is
very strong right now off the board but
instead decides to go ahead and play
this Bishop here to g5 pinning down this
night here on f6 you know it would be
one thing if this knight was on d7 you
know it could protect it but now you
know this Queens just awkwardly being
pinned down by this night so Magnus
Carlsen is gonna have to find a way to
kind of counter-attack that you know
this pinned right here and even you know
a pawn move to h6 you know the bishops
is gonna come back here to h4 still
applying that pressure on the board we
now see the bishop come to e6 kind of
the same idea that we talked about if
the bishop came to e3 is you know white
has this attack on this long diagonal
right here and
you know typically for black this light
square bishop is a little less of a
nuisance and so you know it's not doing
as much so if he can go ahead and trade
this off this is definitely gonna be
good for magnus carlsen and now we see
the knight come to d2 again really comes
here just to get involved into the game
because he can't come to c3 but it's
really not doing too much here on d2 to
be honest oh and that's definitely gonna
want to make sure that he gets this more
involved into the game because right now
it's doing nothing besides you know
protecting this knight on f3 but it's
not being attacked right now another
option that we could have seen you know
we could have seen you know the pawn
come to d4 and then you know the bishop
could take right now again my name's
Carlson wants to get this LightSquared
Bishop off the board you know after we
take here there could be an exchange in
the middle and then after the bishop
comes back you know this Knight can come
to c3 there is double pawns here on the
B file but White has you know a much
more active position he has you know the
the two pawns here on the D and e-file
he's controlling the sinner of the board
again you know an on definitely looked
at this and didn't think this was a
great variation but but something that I
think could have been pretty interesting
for a nod but he decided to just play
that the knight here to d2 wasn't ready
to give up any material in the game so
now we see pawn to h6 again just kind of
pushing it back but not really doing too
much just kind of a waiting move and now
the bishop is going to take here on b3
and so we see the recapture and then
this nights gonna come back here to b8
again if we look at what Magnus Carlsen
wants to do he wants to first make sure
that this Knight is not being pinned
down it again it's just a huge pain with
this bishop here in h4 and so he doesn't
have any real strong attacks the board's
kind of cluttered right now and so until
he can get some of these pieces off the
board he's just gonna rearrange his
knight over here to d7 so that he can
move his Queen away and not have this
night being pinned down because he
doesn't want to recapture here and kind
of leave his King exposed on the King
side so that the Knights of b8 we now
have the pawn push forward to h3 and
then we seed Knight here to d7
now from here White has a few options
and he could do
b4 kind of push this Bishop back
he wants to get his queen involved so we
could play c2 he could play E - if he
wanted to he chose for the night - H -
looking to get it more involved with
night here - g4 again you definitely
don't want to keep it here on H - for
very long Magnus Carlsen could start to
apply some pressure now plays the Queen
to e7 looking to get involved into the
game you know more centralized of e6000
could apply pressure now unfortunately
for him he really can't because there's
no great squares or anything to do but
these Knights on on F 1 and H 2 aren't
doing too much but you know again this
is kind of what you do you you maneuver
your pieces you don't try to force
anything you try to get them in better
positions than they were before and
again here on D 2 and F 3 they weren't
doing too much so now we're gonna see
the bishop come back here to B 6 and
then the Knights gonna come here to F 3
and Magnus Carlsen has the option to
always just come down and take here now
right now this risks gonna come and just
take on e3 so there's no real reason to
give up the Starks square bishop right
now but just something to keep in mind
later on the Queen's gonna come to e6
and then this pawn finally pushes
forward to before and then a6 trying to
open up this a file and so after they
exchanged we see the bishop take right
here and then the site's gonna come to
g4 trying to get more involved into the
game obviously on h2 it's not doing too
much now the bishop comes back I still
wants to apply that pressure over here
and now we see the bishop take and so
the knight can recapture as we talked
about and after the knight takes kind of
interesting that the nominee know a lot
of these minor pieces especially as
you're white he wants you know the
expose the option at least to go ahead
and put a lot of pressure but giving up
more and more material in the game
doesn't always you know lend to that so
now the Queen's gonna come here to g4
and this is interesting because you know
Black has now the opportunity to come in
and just take with his Bishop here on e3
whereas before you know he could try
something so he's kind of protecting
this because after the bishop takes here
on Eve
this pawn has to recapture the route
can't recapture here on e3 because then
the rooks just gonna swing down here and
take and obviously blacks gonna be up
the material so definitely interesting
choice for the Queen to come to g4 it's
not really doing too much right now
and so Magnus Carlsen immediately
although he wants to maintain this
bishop he recognizes that if he can go
ahead and put these double pawns right
here if he can maybe attack this pawn
here and have these isolated double
pawns this is definitely gonna be good
for him as they go into the end so we
look at what white could have done and
you know instead of bringing the Queen
here he could have always first taken
with his rook here on a8 and then you
know after the recapture now if he
wanted to he could bring his Queen
involved into the game so if now the
bishop took he could just recapture with
this rook again and the game that's not
what happened instead we see the Queen
come down and now we have these pawns
right here now the Queen's gonna come
back here to e6 and then we have the
rook swing over trying to control the
semi open file and then probably would I
consider one of the best moves in the
game although it's small Magnus Carlsen
recognizes that there's these doubled
pawns here on the e-file and he wants to
try to chip away at you know this pawn
right here on d3 so that because right
now this is not too bad you have double
pawns but you have this protection so
you know depending on you know this
could take right here or this pawn could
take and then all of a sudden you know
it's not too bad but if this pawn can
come off the board this is really gonna
be super awkward for nan to try to
defend and so after the King comes to h2
we see pawn push forward to c4 this is
exactly what Magnus Carlsen is trying to
do you know if there's a pawn take right
here and then recapture all of a sudden
there's doubled pawns and there's no
there's no way for white to really do
anything except have an awkward palm
position so definitely a great move for
Magnus Carlsen anons decides to push
forward with you know pawn to d4 you
know this would be great news right here
if we could just take right here Magnus
Carlsen is not going to do that instead
he plays you know first takes is rook
over here on a1 and then after the
recapture then the Queen comes over and
starts to attack kind of chip away right
here so that you know after the row
comes here to d1 the
Queens gonna get more involved the Queen
comes up here and now after the
recapture it's very interesting how we
have to take the pawn taking right here
where none would like to do can no
longer work because now the Queen can
just come here to e4 Black's gonna be
out the material is being protected by
this rook so White's almost forced to
take with you know his rook here on the
four also gonna be a mistake if he takes
with you know his pawn here because
again the Queen can just come here
that's stuff I'm gonna be bad so magnus
carlsen almost forces anon to have these
double pawns here on you know e3 and e4
as you see from the rest of the game and
on just has a really hard time of
controlling the equality in the game and
Magnus Carlsen slowly chips away in the
endgame which is where he is the most
dangerous if you slip up in any anyway
in the end game even if it's very very
minimal he can just pounce on to you cuz
again this is where he's the best so
we're here we see the route come down to
e5 getting more involved into the action
attacking the Queen the Queen's gonna
move back and we see some maneuvers and
we kind of go through and both both
sides are just kind of feeling each
other out they also want to get to move
40 right now we're on move 34 and so you
get two hours for the first 40 moves and
then after that you get an additional
hour for the next 20 moves and so both
sides if if you kind of look at it they
don't want to make any huge mistakes but
they're starting to run low on time and
so more than anything they just want to
slowly improve their position but then
get into that 40 move mark and then they
have a fresh hour that they can kind of
take a look at the game and see okay how
am I gonna go into the endgame so the
the King's gonna swing over and then a
few moves later if we kind of look at it
both sides aren't doing too much to be
honest which is kind of expected but as
soon as we see this this Queen come back
here a little bit we see some exchanges
right here as we get into the 40th move
and so after the 40th move we now have a
rook in game but again magnus carlsen
has this slight lead he is now up one
pawn in material definitely something
that he's comfortable with we saw this
in the last game where he was
to take this find a small advantage and
then go on to win the game
so whites now going to attack the pawn
over here on b5 and now the Brooks gonna
swing over and defend this and now
blacks just gonna start to push again
pawns are meant to be pushed in the
endgame and so that's exactly what
Magnus Carlsen does and so as we kind of
come through Magnus Carlsen is just
slowly pushing up his pieces trying to
maintain the tension and so as we come
through
- Carlson decides he wants to go ahead
and just give up this pawn over here he
wants to swing his rook starting to
attack this King over here he has the
majority on the King side and so that's
where he wants to put the pressure over
here on the the Queen side anon has the
advantage so he wants to start pushing
on the Queen side so as far as what both
sides want to do that's it Magnus
Carlsen pushing on this side an on
pushing on the Queen side now see the
King moved down and again the pressure
just starting to to push a little bit
this pawn h4 is very important because
after the the rook swings over the King
can come to h5 still protect both of
these ponds but you definitely don't
want to get into a situation where your
King has to move back here to you know
f6 or even an awkward square of e or f4
and then this rook is kind of
controlling it you can't move past it so
now the rooks gonna swing over here
again greater square for this rook right
here you can also now come to g4 and
then g3 if you wanted to starting to add
some pressure after their work comes
over here that's exactly what magnus
carlsen does starting to force this King
away now we see the King come over here
to to g5 you know you know protecting
this pawn right here an on really has to
you know take this pawn on c4 and then
he needs to start pushing out the board
where Magnus Carlsen is just going to
keep pushing these pawns and there's
gonna be nothing that an on can do so he
checks the King and then he comes back
over here to c4 Manglish Carlsen seems
to be okay with giving up this pawn and
so he does lose this pawn and so both
sides have three pawns and this
particular case it's you know has a lot
of this the GM's that were actually
commentating on this game this is
theoretically a drawl both sides have
three ponds blacks pushing on one side
White's pushing on the other but
theoretically of both sides play
correctly this should be a draw even
though you know there's a lot of ponds
on the board that can do stuff
after the ponds F for this is kind of
where it fell apart for a non magnus
carlsen is pushing on the kingside and
if we look from the Queen side there's
really only one thing that the non
should be thinking about and that's
counter pushing on the Queen side so he
needs to be playing pawn to b4 and then
again it's gonna be a race but it's
gonna be a drawl in the end of it
instead he plays rook over here to a4
which just kind of loses time and all
you need is just a little bit of time in
this game and you can actually go ahead
and win the game so this pawn pushes to
h3 there's really only one option and
that's to take with the pawn right here
but all this does Magnus Carlsen is okay
with giving up material he wants to have
this open door for this pawn to push
forward with his pawn all the way down
here so now we see pawn to c4 again just
to slow you know he's definitely going
to lose the race and so we see f3
and now the rook coming to a3 but it
doesn't matter after the King to e2
Magnus Carlsen is just pushing there's
really nothing stopping Magnus Carlsen
right now he can try to check all he
wants to but after the the rook comes
down here to g1 it's pretty much game
over you know even if the route comes
over here to f8 check you know III this
is there's just no way to stop it
and so Anan looked at it and said good
game and so we see him game six Magnus
Carlsen has won and taken a massive
advantage halfway through this
tournament we see six games left and he
has a to win advantage which is gonna be
very very difficult for an on to come
back from I just don't see how an on can
win two of the next few games without
Magnus Carlsen winning any of them so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this game I
definitely think we're gonna have a new
champion and a few weeks which is kind
of exciting such
young player so so give these magnets
Karlsson so hopefully you enjoyed and
I'll see you on the next video thanks
for watching